so one of the things that um
over the years absolutely shocked me
about anything banking and finance
related
uh was how non-predictive
the technologies were everything was
pretty much uh
counting what was happening uh
facilitating things that are happening
now
uh but it was very hard i think and some
of that was due to lack of technology
some was due to lack of
data some was due lack of just time and
energy spent building it
uh on more like the predictive analytics
and kind of using what we know today to
tell us what's going to happen in the
future
it feels like this open banking embedded
banking
kind of busts down that wall and creates
a world where there's so much data and
there's so much technology and so many
integrations that
there really can be and maybe there is
being a very
big rise in a lot of these predictive
technologies
um i completely agree with you but
what's interesting is
i that's where i think this theme of new
kind of data companies
is what is the next next thing
okay so today yeah so today everybody's
trying to act
on um you know
these breadcrumbs that we leave
all around the world right and a bank is
a bank or somebody else is trying to say
hey which are the best customers to lend
to
based on the linked what's happening
with this business on linkedin how many
people they're hiring what they've
bought
etc and what
i think is the future and what we've
based our company on
is what i'm calling like the custodial
age of data
and what i mean by that is that the new
kind of data opportunities
will morph from their current state
which is this this massive
amount of side effect information that
you then need to apply
ai on to to you know make sense of
um you know she read an article on
business process automation
right and so let's feed her ads for the
for every crm and workflow app
out there there for the next 12 months
i'm currently experiencing that so it's
one of my pet peeves right
instead of feistband we think that the
most interesting opportunities
will arise from the intentional sharing
of actual data and actual intent
with bounded and enforced usage rights
around that data
and so when you talk about like the ai
implications
right instead of having it being
artificial information
what about having it being actual
information
um and you know the best predictor of
the future is actually the past
right um so the most interesting new
platform businesses
you know in my opinion won't be the ones
that are amassing the most data but but
instead they'll be the platforms
that provide the best access
data owner control and watermarking
services
um to the data exchanges that
matter right and the data exchanges that
matter
i believe are you know between a bank
and its customers and okay so let's
dig a little bit deeper on that because
i think it's a really interesting view
of the world uh historically let's take
you know social media companies finance
companies all these different types of
companies
uh they basically had a couple of
different assets
uh most financial investors would look
at
how much revenue do you have what's your
profitability how many users do you have
all that kind of stuff inside of the
companies and literally i worked at
facebook for two years so i know
uh the more access information you have
the better you can make the product the
more personalized the more contextual
the longer somebody will stay the more
ads you can serve kind of
you know one of the assets is definitely
the more information i get the user to
give me
uh the better this is for us as a
company
right it's kind of one of the the key
tenets what it sounds like you're
talking about and that's true
to banks and others as well right it's
kind of the more information
the better what you're talking about is
actually almost
flipping the model and saying no the
winners of tomorrow are going to be the
people who don't
look at it as uh from the corporation
seat instead they look at it from the
user seat and they say what can we as a
business do to empower this user to have
the best experience the most privacy the
most efficiency
kind of all of that and a lot of it's
actually going to be not to hold on to
the data it's going to be to give the
user the data to give them permissioning
to give them
all sorts of tools that maybe
historically they haven't had
because incentives weren't aligned
between the corporation and uh and the
end user is that fair to say
that's not only fair that's probably a
better way of saying it than than i do
at my pitch so i'll invite you to
my next sales pitch no no no you you do
a fantastic job
um but in all seriousness like when i
you know as i talked about you know
founding
fastband sitting there quietly in my
basement googling away
um i believe that
the value of phi span to our customers
the banks
and ultimately to allow them to provide
value to their customers
is precisely because i
as fi span assert no ownership
or usage rights over any of the data
that traverses my network right so um
and the apps i built
on behalf of the bank so our jpmorgan
chase you know
uh erp extension isn't branded fi spam
it's it's branded jpmor it's a it's a
service of jpmorgan chase
to their customer but nonetheless if
it's a product
i'm building i'm building permissions
inside of it
right and if when you click and install
this extension
and you say i agree to share the vendor
file my vendor file with the bank
it's not for the purpose of the bank
marketing to those vendors it's for the
purposes of the bank
to uh provide me with a better accounts
payable risk management experience or
something like that
so that's just our policy and we think
that that's going to build value in the
future and we are
an example of a new kinds of
you know data platform but there'll be
many more
other kinds of examples of that got it
and then in terms
of um that
from a product building standpoint
it do you have to have full end-to-end
encryption
so that not only do you not have
ownership or usage of the data but you
actually can't see it
or is this a situation where you kind of
can't really
do the job that the products intended to
right if you can't see the data so it's
kind of like this
hybrid model of you don't want ownership
you don't want um uh usage
it's more of just like a permission that
the user told me to do x with their data
i go do that job and then i don't do
anything else until they tell me to do
something else right
yeah yeah um
we're not there yet and um
so i i see i
absolutely see what you're saying um but
it just
happens that our business model is we're
both a
you know technology outsource and
servicing outsource component of the
bank
so in order to service the clients we
need to see that data
yep and that's what that would be my
expectation in that
it's different for like and for those
that are listening who may not
who may think that we're in the weeds
here for a second uh take facebook for
example
uh if lisa and i are both on facebook
and i send her a message
uh other than for advertising purposes
there is no need for facebook to be able
to read what message i sent to lisa or
what message she sends back to me
so you can have kind of full end to end
the cr encryption where only lisa can
read it or only i can read it
facebook doesn't need to see that now
facebook would like to see it because
they'd like to target us on advertising
whatever
but for the intent and purposes of what
we're trying to do in communications
and encryption makes a lot of sense when
it comes to this information though
you can imagine if you interacted with
your bank
but they couldn't see the amount that
you were sending they really can't
kind of do their job right so there's
certain pieces of information obviously
that they need
uh which would make sense in this
situation yeah so
um we where we're also
not there yet from a technology
perspective
is um you know there's there's oauth
there's all sorts of encryption
tokenization
that technology exists but i haven't yet
seen an embodiment of
the what i'm calling watermarking of
data which is like
having its intended permissions
around its usage um being enforced
end to end so that technology doesn't
exist but we're starting to
within the industry have discourses
about it so whoever invents that i think
will be
and it's not going to be me but that
will be another example of a very
valuable
technology and business to be entered